hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan today
maintain a question from one of my
newsletter readers re who wrote in
asking thank you so much for the useful
information I have one question for you
i'm doing a masters i want to work in
management problem is up English is my
second language and I'm afraid of making
a mistake while communicating with
others sometimes I may not understand in
casual conversations especially when
they're making a joke I'd appreciate
your response so thanks for the question
I feel your situation I think what's the
most important thing really to think
about at the start and this is for
anybody who's facing any kind of fear
you can't let fear hold you back if it's
starting the business if it's learn a
new language if it's doing something
that you're uncomfortable with it's not
to be scared right and that but gets
your adrenaline going it gets your
juices flowing a little bit it's natural
to be scared but it's doing those things
that scare you that allow you to live to
your full potential and if you don't do
something because you're afraid of it
you're always going to regret it you
know you're gonna look back and regret
not having taking that chance and people
really regret the chances that they took
it's the ones that they didn't take
because they're too afraid to do it so I
don't want fear to hold you back from
doing this and for anybody who's trying
to you know start a business or whatever
it is that you're afraid of tackle it
you know go through with it so that
you're not regretting it later on in
life now specific to language you know
the best way to do it is to practice and
that's for anything too if you're afraid
of starting up start up start up small
and just do something every day to move
that business forward if you're trying
to learn the language do something every
day to immerse yourself in that culture
and that setting so you're always
practicing and practicing and the more
you do it the more comfortable you get
the better you'll get more you'll
understand and you know the more
successful you'll be at whatever you're
trying to do so the easiest way to get
over if your iphone is to start small
what I found is typically when you're
afraid of something is because it seems
too big to insurmountable your skill set
is nowhere close to where it needs to be
so try to break it down to little pieces
and I'll try to do something really
small everyday and suddenly that you
know big huge mountain that look really
scary isn't so scary anymore because
you've already started taking those
steps to climate and you're you're a lot
more comfortable moving forward on it so
I really don't want the fear to
you back you want it to be a counselor
you know what fear to guide you a little
bit make sure you're not doing you know
stupid or reckless things but you don't
want it to be a jailer you don't want to
prevent you from doing things that you
really should be doing and allow you to
lift your full potential so hope that
helps last thing about the language is
it's also increasingly becoming a more
global culture the people I deal with
with in my business or from around the
world everybody has different accents so
many people are English as a Second
Language so you know you got to get used
to it people will be understanding of
where you are and will hopefully try to
accommodate you obviously the better you
can you know bring up your skills to
meet them it will help you but I
wouldn't be too afraid of what other
people think because they're used to
dealing with with people from different
cultures and different languages at
least I am and that's kind of part of my
daily living with running my business so
hopefully that helps again don't let
that fear hold you back if you guys
watching like the video please give it a
thumbs up below it always makes me to do
more these videos for you and you have a
question about your business feel free
to leave in the comments below I always
read those and try to respond to
everybody as soon as I can so thank you
and you'll see on the next episode
you